Your thoughts
attract things with a force that you
cannot see but is definitely real.
Okay, this is me thinking about pizza.
Don't look at me. I ended up watching
this documentary called The Secret and
oh my goodness, it it literally just
opened my eyes. I really felt as if it
was
the secret that I was waiting for. The
ultimate goal of meditation is to you
know try to get get in touch with maybe
different spirit guides and entities.
But you so you empty your mind and you
try to to invite and get in contact with
entities that are smarter than you. And
you know in the Bible we call we call
these demons, right? Franz, you grew up
into Christianity and then you read or
watched a documentary about The Secret
which I think a lot of people have heard
about. I've seen a trailer for the movie
about The Secret and that's where you
started dabbling with the new age. So
tell me how did this all happen? How
could you come from Christianity to the
new age? Oh yeah, absolutely. So I
actually grew up in a Christian
family.
And when I was about 9 years old my
father passed away. Back then we I was
born in Haiti.
I moved to the United States, lived
about 4 years in the states.
And we ended up um
moving to Canada which is where I
currently
am. And this is where this whole story
started.
So I moved to Canada when I was about 13
years old and in the beginning
on a weekly basis I was going to church
with my mom and my siblings.
So I had a pretty normal childhood other
than the passing away of my father.
And then
slowly as time went on I started to
attend church less and less.
I started to meet friends from high
school and from other places.
And by the time I was
17 16 or 17 years old I pretty much
considered myself an agnostic. I
entirely stopped going to church.
I started smoking cigarettes, drinking
alcohol.
I was going to different parties
whenever I was invited.
And I don't know but for some reason I
had thoughts of becoming wealthy and
and rich and so I started to read all of
those personal development books. You
know you like The Millionaire Next Door,
you have
one one of them that I really enjoyed
was
Think and Grow Rich by Napoleon Hill.
Well, I've heard of that.
Yeah, personal development books and
then I ended up watching this
documentary called The Secret and oh my
goodness, it it literally just opened my
eyes. I really felt as if it was
the secret that I was waiting for. It
talked about the law of attraction.
Yeah. Is this documentary the same as
the book The Secret that people know
about? I haven't read the book but yes
it is. It's
I think the documentary was based on the
book. Yes. So what is it about because I
haven't heard of this. So and maybe
those at home haven't either. What is
what is this documentary about?
I read the book before the documentary.
Yeah. Wait, like when you were a
Christian already or before that?
I was not a practicing Christian at the
time.
It's interesting because of I shared the
same sort of like beginning. I was
Christian growing up and then sort of
left for many years.
I just was like that's not right. Even
though I couldn't like quite explain it
in that way. I remember reading it and
go that's not how it works.
But it's basically thinking yourself to
be rich and you're like manifesting
these things because you thought and
dwelt on them and you willed it into
existence.
like the law of attraction. Just like
the law of attraction.
Okay, so manifest manifest station
pretty much.
and it's always like you know framed in
like get as much money as you want. Get
the job you want. Get all the women that
you want. You know it's like things that
that just me me me me me. I see. And
that's why I think I kind of like when I
first originally wrote it I read it I
was like hmm
I don't know if that's going to actually
work.
Yeah.
For me it was really like the law of
attraction aspect that really caught on
to me because
I was thinking like oh my goodness, I
can literally manifest the life that I
want
simply by you know doing some
visualizations and meditations.
So after I saw that documentary I just
started to read a whole bunch of
different books on this particular
subject. Right, I mean books such as
some of my favorite authors you have Dr.
Wayne Dyer. You have Eckhart Tolle
and there were different gurus also that
I was a following.
One of them was Bashar. I'm not sure if
he's still around. So different gurus
that I was following, different books
and really diving deeper and deeper into
the new age. Yeah.
Wow. Yeah, it's interesting. The new age
is is kind of a fascinating
because it it's almost like it gives you
sort of the the elements of of belief
but with no kind of God. Like it's
really just sort of replacing this like
worship of God and then it's like you
know you kind of become that God and
that's kind of seems like what the end
goal is.
Yeah.
And yeah and
also during that time
for some not totally related but I
I
developed this addiction to a
pornography and so
like this very heavy and deep depression
came over my life.
To the point where
I felt as if I was living every day in
some sort of thick fog. Very thick fog,
unable to feel happy.
I was constantly sad and just unable to
enjoy life. And so for me the the new
age and the law of attraction it was not
only a way to achieve a financial
success
but it was also a way to cure my
depression because of the hope that it
gave me, right? No matter how bad things
are but if you simply continue the
rituals, continue your visualizations.
I was reciting different mantras
every night.
There was like this hope that that the
the new age had promised. What kind of a
mantra did did they suggest to do? Well,
it was more
sometimes it was affirmations, right?
Like oh I am happy, I am this.
Different you know self affirmations
that I would recite. Sometimes they were
like different arms like
like different type of sounds that that
they would
encourage me to recite. On
different nights to try to get in touch
with your inner self and uh
yeah.
But sort of just a short-term fix. You
would feel better but then all of a
sudden kind of
it would wear off and you would kind of
feel like you were back in that
depressed state. Well, what I feel I
don't know if if it
literally made me feel better right
then. Well, I actually felt more zen
like more um
like more empty.
It's the best way that I would do.
Sometimes I would try to sit down and
try to meditate and I would empty my
mind and try to think about
maybe
some sort of light inside but
I would simply feel more empty.
I'm not even sure if it felt me happy or
if
I think what what
what caught on to me was mostly the hope
that it promised. Like if you if you
continue you're eventually going to
reach some sort of nirvana and
yeah, ascension. How's your family at
this point? Like is your mom kind of
watching you kind of go through these
motions and
Yeah. Well, my family to be honest they
they were they they were they were never
they were never
like aware of what I was
doing well because most of these things
I practiced them in secret. Like I never
told my my mom that I was doing
meditations and visualizations
but of course my family was very sad
because of the fact that I initially
stopped going to church on a regular
basis and so my mom always tried to
encourage me to come back to come back
to church but it didn't really
interest me. And there's also something
else that I have to mention was that
to me the new age was actually a way of
justifying Christianity.
Right? It was actually a way of me
saying oh you see God does exist, you
know? Angels do exist, right? You have
all of
because in all of the books that I read
and in all of the videos that I saw
all of the documentation on the new age
I never once
like read anywhere that Jesus was bad,
right? I never once read anywhere that
oh you have to worship Satan and Jesus
is someone who's very bad. No, very
often they will actually
you know talk good things about Christ,
right? You know like one of the Eckhart
you know Tolle books
that I read for instance he mentioned
that you know in the past we had
different you know leaders and Jesus was
one of them and he was a very good
person. So very often they would talk in
in a positive light about Jesus.
So to me it was actually a way of of
proving that wow, maybe what I was what
I learned in the past about maybe wasn't
all a fairy tale. Maybe there was
actually something there.
I wonder how many people have this same
experience. Like like
you know you see them in in a lot of
different new age circles like talk
about you know Jesus is being this good
character but you're learning that you
know there's all these other people in
life too and they're all kind of in the
same boat, the Christ-consciousness that
Eckhart Tolle is always talking about.
And so it's like they're capturing
people that want to have a faith or or
have had a belief system at some point
in time, and then sort of disarming you,
but then leading you just gently away
from actually just a relationship with
with God. Mhm. Yeah. Yeah, it's true.
It's because to me that's what that's
what I actually caught on to me.
When I saw that, oh, they're actually
because after I got once once I left
Christianity, I had nothing against
religion. It's simply that, oh, well,
maybe this stuff doesn't really exist or
it's history. I simply just slowly lost
my faith. But I I didn't have any grudge
or any hatred, but I
had, you know, respect for for the
church system.
I had nothing against my the pastors or
anything. So. Yeah. So yeah, it's pretty
disarming.
Yeah, if they would have said, oh, you
know, Jesus Christ is really bad and
evil, it would have turned me off
instantly. Yeah. Interesting. So France,
before we continue with the story,
Scotty mentioned Christ-consciousness.
Have you ever practiced that and can you
explain what it is and is this something
that as as Christians we can practice or
not? Well, the Christ-consciousness is
um Well, because
the New Age talks a lot about for
instance achieving
like some sort of God state right on
Earth
and you can do that through you know,
the different
through um visualizations, through
meditations, and by trying to getting in
touch with what they call spirit guides
or different ascended masters.
And the Christ-consciousness is
cuz you have many different um
like angels and spirit guides and the
Christ-consciousness is one of them.
That you can try to get in touch with.
And this is uh It's a deception, right?
It's There's nothing Christ about the
Christ-consciousness. It's it's
It's
It's like as if they're trying to
manipulate Christianity. And trying to
integrate it into the
the belief system. But it's totally
totally satanic. It is cuz
from what I understand it too is it's
like they say Jesus basically was the
the highest form of thinking, but you
too can be like that. So it's It goes
all the way back to the Garden of Eden.
You could be just like God. Here's how
you try to get to those steps and it's
really like leading you through all
these ascended people that are educating
you till you basically realize you're
God. So Christ Yeah. in the New Age is
like another angel and
He's He's the example of what everyone
should be trying to attain. And so you
try to become God yourself.
Pretty much. Is that Is that kind of a
fair assumption? I think that's kind of
what it's after. Yeah. Yeah, that's what
That's what I saw. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. And And I mean, it's you
know, that it's once again, it's like
using all of these buzz terms and things
that people would be familiar with in
Christianity and instead of outright
just like painting a bad picture of it,
they kind of just put a spin on it, so
you're disarmed. You feel Right.
comfortable if you've grown up in
Christianity to be here. Not that you're
like engaging with demons, you know.
Well, and also the thing is if you think
about Christ-consciousness like you guys
explained it is like it's almost similar
to the Bible cuz it does say, hey,
imitate Christ. Like be like him and he
he helps you In a way it sounds
biblical. Yeah, in a way it sounds
biblical, but it's not like you become a
God. Right. You know, you become You
don't become Christ.
Right. You know, the the snake in the
Garden of Eden, you will be as like God,
right? And aren't we wanting to be like
God?
But the insinuation of what that serpent
was meaning is different than what our
made in the image of God or, you know,
we're trying to have Christ's character
or something like that.
Right. And it's just a slight focus
shift and I think that's what really
leads people away. Right. Yeah.
For instance like in Christianity if you
want something, you you pray and you ask
God for it. Whereas in the New Age if
you want something, you manifest it and
you create it. I'm so I'm so glad you
just said that right there.
Yeah. That's the heart of
And also sometimes Yeah, and also
sometimes when I was in the New Age some
what I would do is
I would just sit down and I would
meditate and do my visualizations.
And then after I would get on my knees
and pray and ask God and me my in my
mind I was increasing my chances of uh
or
trying to get what I wanted faster
by doing both, but
you know, in the Bible God says you
cannot serve two masters. So you cannot
go and do your visualizations and then
get on your knees and pray to Jesus
Christ.
It's such a self-reliant
view of of of reality.
You know, God is the the great I Am. I
am everything to you. I'm your provider.
I'm your lord and savior. I'm your king.
I'm your He is everything to us, right?
And And these kind of things just you
know, put that sort of God-like powers
in your hands.
Mhm. And if you just think hard enough
or you just do X Y Z long enough or
whatever, you become that. And I think
that's interesting that you France were
kind of like stepping in between both
worlds. Right. And And you know, it's
like I wonder if if they allow you or,
you know, don't discourage you from,
yeah, go go pray to God and maybe you
don't get those things, but then maybe
they give it to you when you're on your
own, so you think, well, that was more
powerful than asking God.
Now, why do you need God at this point?
Right. Right, cuz you essentially are
willing whatever you want into
existence.
Which makes it easy to understand why is
it so appealing
to be in like especially for young
people, right? They come out and uh you
know, I just manifest this, manifest
that, manifest the life I want. Mhm.
Right. I'll be my own God. Mhm. Again,
back to the lie in the Garden of Eden,
right? You'll be like God if you just do
this.
Mhm. Right.
What do you need God for if you can do
it all? Mhm.
Yeah.
So France,
going back to your story, so you were
reading these books, you're watching The
Secret documentary. You got into the New
Age and And what happens next? Like how
deep did you get into it? Yes, well,
well, I How deep did I get into it?
Well, I
I felt that as if, you know, I
When it I was actually trying to cuz to
me it just felt so fascinating. Like
this whole
it was like a like a whole other
universe and
also I find I found it a lot more
intriguing compared to right
Christianity. You go to church, you sit
down, you you know, listen to the pastor
and then you go you go home. Whereas in
the in the New Age you have all of you
you feel as if you have all of this
control all of this power. And if life
is bad right now, it's because of you
and your own thoughts and you
right? Um
However, what I did notice was that the
deeper and the deeper that I got into
in in the New Age the more supernatural
experiences that I started to notice in
my own life. Um so I developed this
thing called the sleep paralysis. And
basically where you're stuck in a state
where you're partly awakened from your
sleep. And I used to have uh
like experiences like this pretty much
on a weekly basis, like many times per
week. Like I would have I would get
stuck in this state.
And some of the experiences were
extremely scary. And some of them were a
bit less less scary.
Um One of the scariest experiences that
I recall was I was lying down on my bed
and then I fell into this state. So I
became 100% paralyzed.
Um but I was still aware of what was
happening in the room. And then when I
looked straight in front of me towards
the end of my bed I saw this black
shadowy figure.
And I just simply became paralyzed with
fear. It looked at me straight in the
eyes. And
I became so so scared. And I tried to
scream because I could hear my mom that
was walking in the in the hallway. Um
but I don't think she heard me. And I
just stuck there completely uh
right uh vulnerable. Uh
so yeah, until I finally snapped out of
it. Um so
that was one of the Yeah. How did you
get into that state? Is it like saying a
mantra or like what put you in that
state?
No, not even. I didn't have any control
over it. So you So it just kind of
happened?
Yeah, well, usually what would happen,
let's say I'm lying down and then
it's as if right as I'm about to fall
asleep
it's as if I get stuck. Oh, interesting.
I become paralyzed.
And sometimes Yeah, I become paralyzed
and I
like I don't have control over when it
when it happens or or how it happened.
It's like it just happens. And in
because when it used to happen back then
I used to read up on it and some people
would say that this is actually it could
be one of the first steps into having an
out-of-body experience. Thank goodness I
never experienced an out-of-body
experience, but it was actually one of
those things that I was considering. Um
one of those next steps that I saw in my
evolution. Yeah. Um the the out-of-body
experience is always kind of something
so interesting, but but I remember Eric
Wilson talking about that. He He had
some out-of-body experiences and it's
very real.
Really? Oh, yeah. What's the purpose of
an out-of-body experience? They actually
when they're in the martial arts would
train
at that dojo that they were doing the
martial arts, they had an exercise and
it was only for the higher-up ones. And
you know, martial arts they it gets to
the place where it becomes very new agey
as well. So, it's kind of like
dovetailing in this kind of a theology.
Um but they would practice going home
and going and doing your laundry and and
walking through your house and he'd be
at the Dojo, but he'd be spiritually so
so to say at his house and he could see
what was going on in the house. It's
wild.
What?
Yeah. Yeah.
Dude,
that's crazy.
did that did that at all trigger you
like, okay, this is something demonic. I
mean, clearly you've you knew that
there's demons in the world, right?
Yeah, right. I mean, because
for some reason it felt wrong. But no
one was telling me it was wrong. I mean,
there was there was a show that there
that I was always listening to. It was
called Coast to Coast AM. And there were
was a lot of guests that the author was
bringing in the show that were talking
about out-of-body experiences and in all
of the literature that I was reading
they they
showed it as something that was positive
to have an out-of-body experience. You
can fly outside of your body
and see different different things,
you know, contact your spirit guides and
spirit angels. Um so
but for some reason like it it it just
felt wrong inside, which is why I think
I never like I never was never able to
let go
completely to in order to be able to
achieve one. Yeah. It's almost like you
know, that Christian foundation. It's so
true of the Bible, right? Train up a
child in the way he should go and when
he is old he will never depart from it.
Sometimes when you're instilled with
those, it's like you have in the back of
your mind like a natural break like I I
can't go there, you know. Like hold up.
I've read about this before in the
Bible. Yeah. And I'm experiencing it.
Yeah. Yeah. Did you recognize it as as
demonic manifestations?
Well, initially no.
Because initially I I simply thought it
was my thoughts. Maybe because I wasn't
you know doing enough positive thinking.
Um so I initially did not
recognize it as something demonic. Um
other than that experience that I that I
I just mentioned which um
it really really bothered me. But what
also what did bother me is the fact that
I did not have control over these
experiences.
Like they would simply happen randomly.
Um yeah, like another time for instance
I was laying down on my bed.
Again, I fell into that state. I was
looking at the wall in front of me and I
saw like what looked like Egyptian
hieroglyphs
that was simply like scrolling on the
wall. Um and uh
sometimes I would you know, be lying
again I'll be in this state and I would
hear like voices in the room as if
people were talking.
But I'm I'm looking at the room. There's
no one there, but I'm like hearing like
mumbling sound.
Um
until I finally become fully awake and
goes away, but
so yeah, they were just happening. I had
no control over it.
But I still continued my meditations,
still continued my
visualizations.
I did get some success with the
visualizations that I was doing, which
encouraged me to continue it more and
more.
I think I was pretty young. I did not
have much money back then. So I was
meditating to I was visualizing let's
say
I visualized I think it was maybe
$10,000 and a a recent car.
Cuz I had a very old car and I had no
money.
Um and
so I I did that visualization for you
know, a few few days, a few weeks and
then
afterwards afterwards I received a call
from the bank. And they told me, "Hi
France, we here in in our file we see
that you're sitting to become
an engineer. Did you know that you're
eligible for a loan up to $100,000?"
And me in my mind I I just became
super excited because I didn't think I
was eligible for that type of loan
considering the fact that I did not have
a job, I had no credit and etc. etc.
So I took an appointment with the
with the person and I didn't end up
getting a loan for $10,000 $20,000. So I
used $10,000 to buy a recent car and
a newer car, a newer used car and
$10,000 was in my bank. But what was
interesting is that it was exactly what
I visualized. So I did get it
but not entirely because it came as the
form of a loan. Um and I think there is
this
verse in the Bible and I think it's
Proverbs um
is it 10:22? It says the blessings of
the Lord
makes one rich and he adds no sorrow
with it. So I did get what I wanted, but
right if it was a blessing that did come
from the Lord, it would not have been a
loan. Yeah. So you see these things that
are
you know, making you rethink everything.
If you didn't really feel comfortable
about it, but then there were the good
things that kept you trapped in it
because they were Exactly. So it was a
bit of both and yeah, something okay, so
I visualized this. It worked. But at
maybe 90% not 100%, right? So
Um but yeah, anyways I I I continued and
and also even at one point I stopped
even after I stopped watching
I I ended up coming to the conclusion
that porn was not so good. So I stopped
watching porn. There was this website. I
think it's called Your Brain on Porn,
which helped me completely break my porn
addiction. So the depression
reduced slightly.
Um but the supernatural experiences
continued.
So
Wow. You know, I wonder if they if they
sort of leak because they want to see
how you're going to react to this.
I think if if if they really fully
blown showed up, started communicating
with you, talking with you, having a
conversation with you, it might freak
you out, especially with your
background. Yeah. Um and you might just
run into the church. But if they
Yeah, if they kind of see how is he
going to react to this? How's he going
to react to that, you know? And it's
like they kind of string you along until
you've gone so far down the road, you're
you're hook, line, and sinker into it,
you know.
You were in it for quite a while and
then obviously like you said, you were
starting to
realize eventually, okay, these were
demonic manifestations and then
what what happened after that? Like what
started making you think or rethink
Christianity?
Yep, that's a good question.
Well, for one what because the part that
was
really bothering me was the sleep
paralysis, right?
I mean, I was scared to go to sleep. I
had this habit of
even
up to today still have it. But I I
have this habit of sleeping on my
stomach because I was scared that if I
would wake up, I was scared I was
hallucinate and see something. Whereas
if I was sleeping on my stomach and so
it would be a bit less scary as an
experience. So that was bothering me and
also I wasn't fully satisfied with some
of the explanations, right? That that I
was getting from the New Age. That is
always just your your you don't have
maybe you need to burn some incense or
you need to you know, thank have more
positive thoughts. So I started to have
some doubts, but still nothing
conclusive.
Um yeah, so I I I continued. I still
continued in that in that route. It's
just I became a bit more fearful of
let's say I tried to have an out-of-body
experience or trying to let's say talk
like physically talk with
what they call one of one of the
ascended masters.
So I think that was really the the only
thing that I was missing. This this
you know, I
was a bit fearful of
reaching that next step. Yeah. So what
happened next? Did you did you
Yeah, so so the way yes and then what
happened was that I I was doing yeah, an
internship at a large aerospace firm.
I had my two vacation.
So I decided to go to to get two week
vacation in Tokyo.
Cuz I always wanted to visit Japan.
And then when I was there, so during the
beginning I simply you know, did some
sightseeing, partying
during the night. And then I decided,
you know what France, it's been almost
like over
you know, 10 years I haven't been to a
Christian church. So
I thought, you know what, I'm going to
go to church. Um you know,
just this time and just take some
pictures and send a picture to my mom
and say, "Hey, look mom,
um things are fine. I mean, Tokyo and
look I even went to church."
So
and I went to a found an English
speaking church there. Um and after the
church service so during that main
church, you know, things were
it was very similar to what I was used
to back in Montreal.
And so after the church service,
we had a potluck and then afterwards we
had like a prayer session and you had to
pray for the person next to you. And the
person
that was praying with yes me filed a
prayer request and I asked him if he
could pray for faith.
So he prayed for me so that I could have
a faith.
And
that was the end of the prayer and the
church service. So I continued my trip
and things you know, were just as they
were before. I haven't noticed anything.
Then afterwards
when I got back to Montreal
in a few weeks maybe two or three weeks
went by
and then I remembered that once I was
just sitting down in my car and it just
hit me like really hard and I noticed I
said to myself, "Hey France,
ever since you came ever since that
prayer in Japan, you haven't had one
one of one instance of a sleep
paralysis.
Wow.
So they it it stopped instantly. Wow.
Yeah. And and I remembered after I had
that realization, I was completely
completely shocked. And because they
were happening almost like two three
times even more like, you know, per
week, right? So the fact that I I I I
was able to have two two weeks three
weeks weeks without even one experience
to me was a complete abnormal. Out of
one prayer.
I started praying. And then
for some reason after I I started
praying and and thanking God and maybe
was asking for answers, I felt like like
almost like I was I became very very
hot. It could have been maybe the
adrenaline or the stress, but I I I felt
like my in my heart it became like very
hot like I was burning or
um so
uh
yeah, like it's as if the temperature in
the car increased by like uh
50°. Um
yeah, so Wow. You know, that's just
amazing to think about. You
You know, somebody walks into your
church and and you know, you say a
simple prayer like that. You have no
idea what that person's truly going for
or going through and and an experience
like this, I mean, can kick off a
catalyst to send you back into the
church and you know, what a simple
prayer, but what a beautiful
illustration I think that God is is you
know, he's demonstrating
he's powerful. He can work in your life,
you know?
So did you end up going to church after
that time in in Montreal?
Well well
after that because I I was going before
that incident deeper and deeper and
deeper into the new age, but then I did
I made the switch. So I went on YouTube
and I started to
you know, read about all of these
testimonies on people that that had
similar experiences to me that went on
new age and for some reason met Jesus
Christ and realized that oh, it was a
deception. So I I became 100% convinced
because before I wasn't convinced that
that the new age was bad. And like I
mentioned earlier, actually to me the
new age was actually a way of justifying
Christianity of saying hey, you know,
the Christians are right. You know,
God does exist. You know, the Big Bang
didn't invent everything. So to me that
that's how I saw the new age initially
and now I realize that oh, okay, it was
um you know, an even bigger deception
than pure atheism.
Mhm. Well, so did you immediately
connect these events to that one prayer
that you had in Japan? Like the no sleep
paralysis, no anything. Did you
immediately think like, oh, I wonder if
it's because of the prayer prayer. Did
that lead you into searching up these
testimonies? Uh well well for me was not
even a question. I was sure it was it
was because of
to me it was it was very clear
after that after I made that
realization
because that's specifically what I asked
for because when I asked the person to
pray for me, I simply asked for faith
and when I asked him to for faith, it's
because in my mind I knew also knew what
I was thinking that okay,
is there something is there something
there, right? Um so and
for and God like showed it to me simply
by removing that that that experience
that I was having regularly and that was
very bothering it was troubling me.
I I have met various Christians who were
practicing Christianity and were
involved with the new age at the same
time,
but your experience clearly shows they
cannot be blended. It's not the same
thing cuz like you were saying this for
you in the beginning it's like, oh, I
can
verify or explain prove Christianity
like this, but
with this act of answering your prayer,
God is saying that Jehovah, the
Christian God, the Bible God is saying,
no, no, no, that's not me. That's from
the enemy. That's from Satan.
This prayer for faith is from me and I'm
not like that. Yeah, absolutely.
And yeah, because the two cannot be they
cannot, you know, work together.
Um yeah, and that's why we have to be
very very careful when we see, you know,
positive things that that are being said
by about Jesus
that's in the new age or in different
books
because there is also Jesus in the new
age, right? It's not the same Jesus
that's in the Bible. Yeah. And and and
they're waiting in the in the new age,
you know, they're waiting for the
Maitreya to come. There's a There's
There's a lot of common kind of like
parallels to Christianity even in the
new age. And I think that's that's, you
know, the truth that lot the lies that
come so close to the truth. Those are
the harder ones to to actually, you
know, distinguish between and
I wonder if a lot of people who are
initially drawn to the new age if if
they really do have, you know,
an a a beginning stage of either
Christianity or, you know, I wonder how
often that actually happens. Yeah.
Yeah. No, I'm I'm really I'm really glad
that that you
you asked for that faith. Faith is
something that's really interesting.
Like what Lucifer lost in heaven was his
faith in God.
Yeah.
He lost that ability to say God is the
rightful ruler of the universe. He
created me. He's He deserves my my
worship and my attention and if you lose
that faith, I think one of the one of
the hardest places to come from is a
Christian background and then to lose
the faith. Mhm. And that the devil just
has a field day with that because once
you lost faith in in either God or the
system,
then it's like the door is wide open for
anything. Mhm. Anything really because
if you're if you come from a Christian
background, you're already used to the
supernatural in a way.
So introducing other stuff that also
have supernatural things is just easier.
So Satan really enjoys saying that.
That's for sure. You know, anybody
that's listening to this podcast and and
is maybe in the valley of decision,
maybe perhaps you're questioning whether
the new age is true or not and maybe you
can't had a Christian background,
I would highly suggest get on your hands
and knees and ask God to open your eyes
and show you the truth. Yeah.
if you just simply ask that, Lord, I'm
willing to to see the truth of this if
you want to show me to show me where
this is airing.
And you know, I think I think God he's
he's a gentleman. He's not going to
force anything on you, but if you ask
him to open your eyes, he'll show you
where it's wrong. Yeah. And pray to the
Christian God, the biblical God.
I mean, if you want to manifest
something, go read the promises in the
Bible. Right. Right. Just ask, Lord, you
promised this, you know, please make it
happen. Right.
If it's your will. If it's your will.
Was it Elisha's servant that he opened
the eyes and he saw all the horsemen
around the things? That was Elisha,
right?
So that's interesting that he didn't ask
for his own eyes to be opened. You know,
he wasn't like, let me see too, God. He
already had that confidence. He already
had the faith of like, look, I there's
there's an army of people around here.
Angels.
Angels. And and I love that prayer. It
was a simple prayer like, hey, open my
servant's eyes. And then it's like, bam,
he had the faith installed right there.
But yeah, faith is faith is a key thing
and you that was very
awesome that you asked for that. God
honored that.
Faith and also making sure like you you
making sure you
know who you want to follow because
after I realized I I had
all of the books that I had, I threw
them away and some different things that
I collected also
um
different even incense that I that I
bought right to put all evil spirits, I
threw all of that away.
Right? And because I realized that I
only needed Jesus in the Bible. And also
I felt more at peace because there's
actually a responsibility like when
you're manifesting your own life,
there's actually a responsibility that
comes with that cuz what if you manifest
something you thought you wanted, but
you know, does it really maybe serve
you?
Cuz you have to know what you want and
then visualize it. I mean, the things
that I was visualizing back then, now I
realize, oh my goodness, thank goodness
that it never you know, happened.
Like
being on the beach somewhere in Thailand
and
I mean,
right?
Whereas if you if you if you pray and
ask God, you
that you can be 100% sure that you're
going to receive exactly what you need
at the at the correct time. So it's
actually a weight that's lifted off of
your shoulders. Mhm. Yeah, it if you
really sit down and you think about
what what do most people use the secret
or any self-help book like that? Um what
are they really asking for? I want
money, I want fame, I want like a bigger
house. I want you know, how many how
many people are actually going, you know
what? I want to bless my community.
I mean maybe some people do, I don't
know, but I but I think if you really
analyze like what are you trying to
manifest? What are you asking for? Is
that really for my own,
you know, benefit or my own selfish
desires or am I actually doing that to
bless other people? And it's like when
you really realize how God works, it's
like he's so others focused, you know.
Yeah. Yes, what happened that yes way um
I threw away all of my um everything
that I that I collected. I started to
read um
uh
you know, learn the power of prayer,
right? Because after that prayer at that
church, I realized like that oh my
goodness, there is power maybe in
prayer. Um so I started to um
uh
what my my coming back into the church
happened gradually. Um so like very
slowly by slowly I started to to come
back.
And uh
um
Yeah, but
but at the same time it was uh difficult
um like I'm still maybe a battling um
cuz I I was in it for so long, right? So
so to
you know, throw all of that away uh at
once was uh
uh it was a challenge.
Uh but at the end I I did ended up
feeling uh more at peace.
Uh I felt more more happy, more more at
peace, right? And uh I always ask
someone if you want to know if if things
are okay,
one uh test that you can do is sit down
on a chair
and um just just sit down on a chair for
5 minutes, right? If you're able to sit
down on a chair for 5 minutes and just
and and be okay, then things maybe are
not so bad,
right? Because when I was in the New
Age, I had difficulty um you know, just
sitting down on on a chair for 5
minutes. I was always like uh
anxious or um
like this this unsatisfaction with life.
And that's even after I stopped the the
pornography, which is when I felt the
heaviest and the heaviest depression. I
was even seeing a psychiatrist.
It was so bad even after I stopped that.
The depression reduced, but the
unsatisfaction with life continued.
Whereas with Christianity,
I felt like there was a a peace that's
more sincere.
Mhm. Yeah, that's why the Bible says,
"Taste and see that the Lord is good."
Or or you know, he promises peace that
passes all understanding. And and if you
give him the opportunity, yeah, just
just observing that in your own walk,
like how much more peaceful and okay you
are at this state, you know, than this
nervous energy, you know, I I I I stand
firm on on give God a try.
Like let him just tell him you're
struggling. He can handle that. But
just, you know, Lord, teach me, open my
eyes, help me to to feel confident or
whatever, you know, and go to God. And
if he wants you to have that, then then
then he'll he'll let you have that. But
if he if if whatever that is that you're
asking for is going to destroy your
life, God's not going to want it to give
you something that's going to ruin you.
And I also had different experiences
also uh like I I um I
when I I prayed and asked God for, you
know, uh for faith, for
for uh there was different things also
that that I was asking through my
prayers and I was able to see the
realization of also of those I was able
to see the responses of of those
prayers. And to see how how genuine uh
you know,
it was and uh so I I find that the
answers from the Lord are usually better
than the answers from
from your your own power, right? Through
visualization and meditation. Mhm.
That's right. Yeah. So now that you're
you're a Christian again,
right?
And you compare it to the New Age, which
one according to you and your
experience,
I mean you you already said you have
more peace, but which one would you say
is like the best option of the two?
Yeah, I mean the uh you know what? In
the because our you know, carnal nature
sometimes we want to be in control. We
want to you know, if you want you want
this big house and this nice car, like
you want to have control over
what you um
oh in over what you what you're able to
to manifest and what you're able to
create. And this is I find you know, the
carrot and the stick for a lot of people
to come into the New Age. Um but at the
end of the day, right? You're
you're always going to have
a more fulfilling life um through
Christianity
by following the very simple nature of
Christ. Um
so yeah, because I feel a lot more even
when I have problems in my life,
I still feel more at peace because, you
know, since you know that God is in
control. Mhm. Amen.
Yeah. It's in ministry, you you you
learn to rely on God a lot. And and you
know, it's like
the ministry's life is kind of up and
down and you know, are we going to get a
paycheck? And in the beginning it was a
lot of of of God teaching us how to rely
and trust on him. But it's it's over the
course of so many times that I've seen
him work, you just learn to go if God
wants this done, he's going to take care
of it. And if he doesn't, then what am I
stressing over it? How's that going to
change anything, you know? Yeah, cuz God
knows what's best for you.
Yeah, sure. We still ask God for things.
Yes, we would like certain things to
happen, but even just projects and
things that our ministry is has gotten
engaged in, it's just, Lord, do you want
us to do this project? If so, you here's
what we need. If not, then I'm going to
take that as an answer. And it takes the
pressure off of us.
And so, you know, in your life, I mean
you can apply that to anything. What job
should I have? How about my spouse? How
about like, you know, what do you want
me to do with my with my life? When you
start engaging with God like that and
asking him to make those things apparent
in your life,
you'll see him work in a mighty big way.
And when you sit there and you're
directing your life, it's like God just
takes a step back and he's waiting for
you to ask him. He's just such a
gentleman about it. So I was listening
to a book this morning, an audio book,
on my way to work. Um and it was talking
about how um it's presumptuous for us to
think that if we ask God this, that
God's going to exactly answer it
according to how he wants to answer it.
That it's actually faith
to say, "Your will, not mine, be done."
And to really give it to God. But it it
at times as a Christian that can be
stressful, but when you really get to
know the character of Christ and really
have a relationship with him,
it's like what Franz is explaining, it's
complete peace. It is absolute complete
peace. And that's the difference that it
seems like with the New Age, with
manifesting, is that I want this and
this is how it's got to be. And you're
trusting in yourself as a human being
rather than this omnipotent, omniscient
God who created you, who was all
knowing, who loves you, who died for
you, and who will only do what's best
for you. To the point where even if
there's no answer, that's an answer, and
it's the best answer. And you can trust
him in that. Yeah. Yeah. The thing when
you have faith is you believe that his
ways are always higher than ours.
Yes. Right? When you have faith, you go
you don't go to God once you believe in
that. You don't go to God with a piece
of paper with the things you want and
like, "Hey Lord, can you sign this off
and give it to me?" Like no, you give
him a blank piece of paper and say,
"Lord, write on that what you want for
me." Cuz we actually believe that. And
be okay with him of however he answers
that. I mean Balaam is a great story,
right? Of somebody that was like, "Hey
God, can I go curse your people?" God's
like, "No." So I'm going to try and try
and try and try again until God's like,
"Okay, fine, go." And then he can't say
anything but a blessing out of his
mouth.
And and you know, what a what a
character. He just goes home and thinks
about it. How can I make these like
these Midianite kings win over the
Israelites? And then he comes up with
that plan that basically lost a lot of
people's lives at the apostasy right
there at the River Jordan. So
you know, be okay when God says, "No,
that's not that's not okay." And and he
shuts a door or anything like that. And
and and you'll see when you learn to
trust God with the yeses and with the
nos.
It really is revolutionary. Someone
recently told me that when you pray for
something, God always answer. But he's
going to give you one of three answers.
The first answer is yes.
Second, yes, but wait.
And no. Yeah.
Amen. Yeah. Yeah. I I
I for the first few years that I lived
in Los Angeles, I tried to be an actor.
And and I went to Christian schools
growing up and and even a Christian
college. And so uh my prayers were,
Lord, help me to book this thing. Help
me to make this this movie part or
whatever like this. And I I made all
kinds of deals with God. I'll give you
all the money. I'll donate the whole
thing to the church. I just just let me
get that part. And I never got the part.
And so, you know, I guess it would be
easy to look at it and say, "Well, well,
well, God didn't answer me." But I'll
tell you what, I I think 100% he
answered me. If I would have gotten
that, maybe I wouldn't be sitting here
today.
And so, you know, he
We'd be making videos about you. Right.
Like, look at this train wreck of a guy
right here, you know. Yeah. I think um
anyone that's
you know, in the New Age should consider
uh you know, um
maybe I try to uh
see that
you know, not everything that that
they're reading is true and that the
it's very um
deceptive, very very deceptive and uh
yeah. The the peace and the truth uh
that comes with Christ is is a far more
superior. Amen.
So, you've been you've been as someone
coming out of the New Age,
how would you say we should approach
people if we know anyone, if someone at
home knows
has a friend who is into that?
Your experience coming out of that, what
would be the best way of approaching
them
to try to bring them to Christ?
Uh yeah, that's a good question. Um
well, the first first thing that I will
say is is to not not judge, right? I
think
you know, one thing
we could help to try to challenge
especially if the person is in contact
with different spirit guides or entities
because very often if you're in the New
Age, you you see these things as
positive. So, just to you know, maybe
put
like a doubt that oh, maybe what you're
the person that the entity that you're
talking to, is it really beneficial? How
do you know that, right? Is it like it
doesn't correspond to to what's in the
Bible?
Um so,
I'll say to you know, be understanding
and and also to to expose some doubts
that
that the entities that they're that
they're maybe getting in touch with are
not maybe not what they they appear to
be. Yeah. You you know, the Bible is
the Bible's got a lot of examples of of
people talking to entities and
things. Um you know, it's it's a
there's some advice in there that would
be great to stick to, but yeah, in in in
your case, um you know, would you have
responded if somebody came into your
life a lot earlier, a few years before
you did convert back? And um you know,
it would have been like, "Hey, that's
that's not right what what you're
doing." How would you have reacted to
that?
Yeah, I mean, that's a good question.
I'm not even sure if I'll have
responded. That's what it's so
it's very sensitive to, right? That the
way we we approach it because especially
when you're so convinced, you know,
about what what you're doing. Like I I I
had like cuz me in my mind, I was not
doing anything wrong. And it was
actually the opposite. I was helping
Christians. I was like, "Wow, I mean, if
someone told me, 'Hey, you know, I'm a
Christian. I'm here I'm actually had
people
you know, come to me with a Bible and
say, 'Oh, hi, I'm a Christian. Maybe
like the different ministers. Do you
want me to pray for you?' And my
response was, 'Hey, I'm a Christian,
too.'" Right? Would you like me to pray
for you? Like I I
So, I did not see the problem in in what
I was practicing, right?
Interesting. I did like there's no where
in the in my mind there was nowhere in
the Bible where it says you know,
meditation is wrong, Mhm. right?
Yeah, in fact, sometimes they use those
see the problem. I Yeah.
Meditate on God's word. They'll I've
heard that from kind of, you know, New
Age like, you know, the Bible tells you
to meditate. Meditate on this. So, why
why why is meditation something we
shouldn't be doing? I mean, we've talked
about a lot on the show, but from you
coming from the New Age, why is this
something that is not what the Bible
says meditation is and we shouldn't be
dealing with it? Right. Well, me in my
experience was that meditation, there's
like different levels and yes, maybe at
the at the basic most basic level, you
just sit down in your chair and breathe,
but I think the the ultimate goal of
meditation is to you know, try to get
get in touch with maybe different spirit
guides and entities.
But you so you empty your mind and you
try to to invite and get in contact with
entities that are smarter than you. And
you know, in the Bible we we call we
call these demons, right?
Um so, I think that's where the the
danger of meditation is because it
could be like a
you know, like a door into having things
come in into your life that maybe you
don't want. Mhm. Emptying your mind when
the Bible says, "Let this mind be in you
as it was in Christ Jesus."
But what about people who say, "Well,
I'm not you know, that far where I'm
like inviting entities in. I'm just
emptying my mind to relax or just
de-stress." What about that? Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, but I think it's always I
mean, it's the same concept with yoga,
right? I mean, yoga, there's nothing
maybe wrong with it when you look at it
at the surface, but what is the purpose,
the true purpose of yoga, right? I think
I see meditation, you know, as as
you know, being the same thing. Whereas
if you're like
yes, if you're simply sitting down on a
chair, breathing, doing breathing
exercises, and meditating, closing your
eyes, there should not be anything wrong
with it, but the true purpose, the true
goal is is for you to go dive deeper, to
empty your mind more, meditate longer
and longer until you eventually reach
the point where you're you're having
entities come inside of of your life,
right? Mhm.
You know, the story that Jesus told when
he cast a demon out of the man and the
demon went away and the man swept up his
house, meaning, you know, he's an empty
vessel, and the demon came to check on
him and when he saw that his house was
empty, not filled, he went out and got
seven more unclean spirits and they came
in, he was worse off than he was before.
It's like almost like what I'm hearing
is if you're emptying your mind and then
you're putting a little picket sign that
says, "Hey, this is an empty house. Come
and have it me."
You know, God is is is wanting you to
invite his spirit in. That's why, you
know, Revelation talks about Jesus
knocking on the door of our hearts,
right? All we got to do is open it up
and let him in. We're we're to invite
God and and the Holy Spirit in
every single day. If we are empty and
then letting whatever inhabit us, I
think that's that's like literally what
the demons want. And when you're when
you're in speaking of yoga in that
context and they're doing hand mudras
and stuff and they're emptying their
mind, it's almost like you're giving the
demonic world a visual cue, this person
wants me to come and you know, for
whatever rules that they have to play
by, it's like you're an open invitation
to let them into your life. An idle mind
is the devil's workshop. Isn't that how
the the saying goes? Mhm. Cuz in the
beginning me when I was meditating, it
was
most people do. I sit down, I close my
eyes, and I I breathe.
But by the end, right towards the like
my my last
periods in the New Age, I was meditating
for much much much longer, you know,
upwards an hour at a time.
And at the end, I started to feel like
electricity flowing through my body,
right? So, the point is it's like levels
and I'm I'm sure there's maybe steps,
you know, beyond that where you know,
sometimes maybe you hear voice like I
don't know. I never reached those next
levels, but I did reach the level where
I felt like electricity in my in my Wow.
So, I mean, it's almost like the alien
topic, right? Have you guys ever heard
like when people see spaceships, they're
usually meditating? Yes.
They're actually inviting that
experience. In fact, if you go out into
a field and you stare up at the sky and
go like, "Please abduct me. Take a take
a spaceship and I want to go up in it."
I mean, I I would not do that,
literally. Mhm. That that that is like
an open invitation for the spirit world
to start communicating with you.
And you know, there's there's a ton of
examples of how people got into that
situation. Due to meditation. Yeah, it's
all starting from meditation.
Yep. I mean, there's so many different
ways to relax. You can do breathing
exercises regularly. You can exercise,
work out. So, there's a lot of different
ways, right, to relax without having to
completely empty your mind and uh
right, visualizing or maybe a circle of
light.
Can you speak a little bit on breath
work as well? Is that something else you
got into?
When you're
meditating, like you'll do different
different types of breathing exercises
to try to relax more and more. Um and
very often they'll ask you to try to
focus in your on your breath.
And then
and then it it you know, goes deeper
from there, right? And after you focus
on your breath and you you they'll
they'll ask you to try to visualize
maybe
like from a flight or visualize your
like your breathing.
Um
So, yeah, in the beginning it it does
maybe help you to feel a bit more
relaxed, but I I think the goal is is is
much much bigger than to simply help you
to to relax. The goal is actually to
help you
you know, like feel more connected with
your
divine or with the
Yeah, because the New Age talks talks
about like this concept that we are all
one, that we are all interconnected,
like all this energy, right? So, when
you're meditating, you're you're trying
to also get in contact with the one,
with with the with God, with the
universe,
right?
Cuz you know, they say that everything
is vibrations. You have different
vibrations and
yeah, so
And that and that's such a counterfeit
because Jesus' last prayer was, you
know, I pray that they be one as you and
I, Father, are one.
You know, it's like the devil just takes
those words and sort of just twists them
and bends them a little bit. Whereas
Jesus is meaning like, you know,
God the Father and Jesus have one, you
know, soul purpose to love their
creation and to engage with them and be
others focused and all those kind of
things. And that's what he was wanting
for his believers to be like that. But
then it's like the New Age takes that
and it's like, "No, we're one." Meaning
just like everybody's the same, evil,
good, bad, you name it, we're all just
one. Yeah, and it's like we're all one
big family. Doesn't matter, you know,
there's no sort of
like-mindedness like that. There's also
a similarity with with breathing
exercises because I actually I'm a
certified small group facilitator for
Dr. Natalie's
community-based depression anxiety
recovery program. It's a mouthful, but
one of the things he teaches is,
you know, when you're stressed, when you
have anxiety, breathe in and breathe
out. There's nothing wrong with
breathing in and of itself, you know, it
actually relaxes you, but that's just a
standard scientifically proven point.
But then, you know, it sounds like the
New Age they take it way farther where
it's like and it's the same with with
with yoga, right? Like
if I'm just going to
uh what was it like a
a cow cat pose where you're just like
stretching your back, you know, I don't
I don't think that there's anything
wrong with that, but once you start
doing it for the sake of yoga, you do it
as a yoga exercise.
Uh remember Blessing, she came on to our
show, she was a pretty well-known, very
I wouldn't say famous, but she was like
really well sought after
it. Yeah, she was just well sought after
yoga instructor that worked at the
high-end places and she was explaining
there's nothing wrong with doing a
stretch to get some flexibility, but
it's when you start putting those pieces
together as like it's like I'm going to
do this stretch and then I'm going to do
this this stretch and this stretch and
I'm actually practicing yoga now,
that's when it becomes signs or sign
language to the spirit world for you to
come in and to get something into you.
Yeah, the thing that she brought out
that that I think was kind of
mind-blowing for me that I'd never
thought about before was it's telling a
story. Yeah.
Like you when you're doing that downward
dog and like the warrior pose and all
that those things in that context in
that row are like telling this like
actual horrible horrible story.
Right.
And and so it's like you're reenacting
that story and that's why in the context
that then becomes wrong. Not that there
you're just sitting there touching your
toes or
stretching up to the sky. It was like in
that sequential system you're now giving
honor to whatever those gods are. Yeah.
Wow. We're thankful that, you know, you
you
found your way back to Christianity and
that that God helped you to to see the
truth and and I'm hoping for the viewers
at home that that if you're involved
with this that, you know, click click on
our channel on our playlist. There's a
an option there for New Age and the
occult and just watch some of those
videos. We'll drop some in the
description as well. But I think it's
worth investing in in this idea that
maybe Christianity and the Bible does
have peace and truth that the New Age
and the occult doesn't have. Maybe
there's something more to this Christian
God and if you
at any point have thought that or had
that question, I encourage you to click
below on
on our playlist and watch some more
videos. But thank you guys so much for
watching and thank you for France for
joining us today all the way from
Canada. Um if you guys would like to
support our channel, you can do so by
going to lls.tv/give
or to patreon.com/littlelightstudios
and either way you get a bunch of cool
perks by donating or you can go to
lightwear.shop. I'm wearing a sweater
right now. Lightwear.
I am, too.
You are, too? Yeah.
There you go.
gorgeous. There it is. Yeah, so you can
get your own t-shirt Christian merch on
lightwear.shop. Support the ministry and
be a walking billboard for Jesus to
start up conversations about our Lord
and Savior. And I think that's a wrap
for today. We'll see you guys next time
on LD Live and uh thank you for
watching.
If you like this video, like, subscribe
and hit the notification bell so you
know when we launch new videos.
And drop a comment below and we'll try
to get back to you if we can.
Say that again.
No, I don't know what to say.